what is up reject nation I am John
Humphrys as a dog barking outside
because this is a real reject video with
me is Kyle I learn men of the fan theory
channel fan theory channel comm correct
that is it yeah you gonna follow them on
Twitter Instagram at the Kyler Minh
please do perfect you can avoid the
tongue twister of saying your name
outright just say that from now and I'm
good with it is much easier now Kyle as
I understand you're a spider-man fan no
I just fill that hole just a wee bit
something tells me you may have appeared
on this channel before talking about
yeah I'm not a comic book expert by any
stretch of the imagination spider-man
has long been though the guy always
resonated the most with you know and I
found this featurette online there's a
new spider-man cartoon coming to Disney
XD the little cats featurette thought it
might be cool to check out yeah yeah
yeah please alright let's go for it
spider-man bring working reverse instead
of absorbing vibrations it's producing
working right I always think a Peter
Parker work so well for so long because
he has been most relatable yep okay pain
oil down Justin might in trouble as a
middle-class kids between may take care
of execs a real walk of life we have a
whole new cast and we went through an
extensive casting process particularly
to Peter
the great thing about Pete is that he's
someone that you can not only relate to
buck look up to all of you like you
you're my cue
there's not one bad going with a mouth
and rallies a young 15 year old science
nerd by everyone but you still haven't
like went safe yet Quincy I have I think
I haven't I mean she is so smart she can
stand up next to him and have these
amazing ideas you know you could have
just created a web fan made a wind
cushions on helicopters air freshener
one of the things that I love about this
show so much is that all of the students
are so capable
what about sending the devices to
transmit without way sorry
Anya breasts on in Latin and she is
really kind of a tough girl time it
needs have a bitter acute she's super
smart intellectual she knows everything
she's looking for a new identification
what I like about Harry is that even
though she grew up privileged and he's
aware of that fact he's still a loyal
friend to PBS to be so rude at a beach
my best friend and presented he's the
competition I play Norman Osmond he's
fabulously successful and wealthy when
it involves my son I remove mountains
naked wouldn't that upset the organic
balance of nature
max Modell is a genius he is well-versed
in all parts of science Maxim Adele here
says something safe our family compares
about students welcome
Rison hi this show is really about
teamwork spider-man a for Clayton
strictly you don't have a superpowers in
order to stand up and fight so you have
all the problems of day-to-day life and
sometimes family and friends and
teachers and your own moral compass to
guide you through all of life's problems
I hope that people take away from this
show is that everybody is here water
cannon ball technically it took me drink
water cannon it's all the right now it's
thrilling and funny and adventurous and
so excited for people to see it I think
that was so great that looks very fun
it's like spider-man and his amazing
friends who are just human but amazing
because they're smart geek and they know
their stuff I think that looks cool oh
yeah I only discovered that this was a
thing just recently and the one thing
I've heard from kind of everybody
involved is that science is the focus of
and it should be it is what's firemen
really is based or mean it's still
science fiction but I mean go science
it's to the science I like the idea of
making a spider-man animated series is
utilizing a lot of science so I love the
idea of having all the thrilling
superhero spider-man stuff but also you
know having a show that cares a little
bit about the science part of things
like that's a part that you don't get to
explore that much in the films or
whatever you know because usually the
science and here for a minute to explode
or something
give somebody powers and then they got a
fight siren yeah oh yeah and I like the
look of the other characters I'm
incredibly impressed by like where we've
come because there's so many variations
of spider-man in the cartoons alone like
there's been so many I think more so
than than even Batman none of them have
ever done anything like this before
whereas all of his friends are helping
out they're kind of putting them all in
there which is really cool it's not just
when Stacy being smart it just gives him
a tip here and there
here yeah there's one thing I like about
amazing environment is oh boy
I actually liked that gwen stacy was
officially a sidekick even though that
movie was a turd Gwen Stacy's role of
like tweaking his cartridges and all
this stuff I thought that was like the
one good thing that I got from that
movie this series looks absolutely
amazing I like how the animation has
kind of emerged between the traditional
American animation with anime yeah
that's the look of this the shapes in
the builds of the characters there's a
simple but they're clean it still has
detail where it should be counting so
you can tell a good story and not focus
on having to make someone's mouth move a
specific way or whatever you know
there's so many gritty and real
iterations of these superior characters
and it's just nice to watch something
like this again where I'm like oh cool
it's a bit more fantasy in a bit more
imaginative and a bit more broad in that
sense a new asset of the unit and I do
like when they have Spider Man in high
school that's truly where Spider Man was
at it's his best I mean even the the
animated the most popular one from the
90s which was the amazing spider-man
they had him start immediately upon
graduation of high school like I was
writing the college right into that
series like spider-man 1 yeah yeah it
was just like that like classic
spider-man 1 was and it was like wait
you should keep him in high school just
a bit longer and that's what I'm excited
about the new movies and everything
because there are so many different
characters and stuff it's nice to have a
superhero who is kind of a kid to me
that broadens out what this whole genre
has become ya know I feel like it's even
more important now that we got like
spider-man homecoming where he is just a
high school story yeah that brought it
out the universe I think it's hilarious
how Aunt May
is basically a young 20-something year
old woman with gray hair and they get
cooler every time we do this I mean like
if you go back to amazing environment
she was like Golden Girls like Sophia
and now she's like I'm this fun cool
aunt who has
hair whose an old lady but totally young
yeah totally young man hip ass right out
of college young like what I don't know
if I want this to be the trend forever
but at the moment that it's happening
I'm like okay all right Marisa Tomei and
hip yeah that's exactly what I thought I
was like she seems really sprightly for
her age like this is the ma I think of
usually like PE you know yeah rosemary
Harris PE now this was really cool I'm
going why we decided to look at this you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
hit that notification Bella get notified
every time a video or a review is out
Skyler Minh on Twitter Instagram the fan
source channel dot no I'm sorry I mix
you an Andhra fan Theory channel calm
you can come check us down on patreon
we've got all kinds of exclusives and
fun things over there come join our
community we got t-shirts on Spreadshirt
and until next time I love each and
every one of you peace